it's not what he's playing it's not the
court
that he's hitting you know it's
what's between it it's the stop it's in
between it
that that that is where
you feel the story he's telling
in the music
how did you figure out your voice i
yelped into the wind
and um no uh
you know what i i you know when you
asked me that question
immediately the first thing that popped
into my mind
and it really has nothing to do with
anything we're discussing
um was um
the first few lines
of james joyce's portrait of the artist
as a young man
and what that
story um and that book means
as a um as a
as a tale um about
this this modernist tale
um that is descriptive of how
an artist reaches his voice
that is descriptive in
in the way that it tells
how that artist reaches his voice
because anybody familiar
with portrait of an of an artist knows
that
it is a um it starts with um
these kind of weird little phonetics
because
he's like he's just a he's just a baby
and he like he's like
looking out on a pastor and he sees
cows and he's like moo cow and stuff
like that
and it's and and then it slowly develops
into
what becomes a language that starts to
become sophisticated which is uh
the um the
is considered like what people said was
brilliant about james joyce and it is
brilliant
um um also they said that james joyce
well james joyce apparently was um very
he was very very influenced it was like
he was the very first generation
of of of uh
novelists that were influenced by cinema
cinema had influence on
writing the novel as opposed to
and that was early cinema very early
sooner
yeah because i just got lost in thinking
about portrait of the artist
it's such a good book
we'll put a link down to it below you
know um
it's um okay so how i figured it out um
i talked a little bit about that before
and
that that really was um
kind of discovering um how to
write in these terse sentences um i
already had
a um a a
a sense of how to write decent dialogue
um and um i was
i i was just honing that along with
um creating these little terse
um bursts of
of description to create the scene
structure
[Music]
that was working for me um
simultaneously i learned how to outline
um now outlining
for me at that time was um
something i i used a structure of 12
beats
um i think it's a i think
in the beginning the way i i worked it
out
and also the way i was taught because
there was various
areas that i um i um
i picked up some of the the skill set
that i had
i'd read um of course the art of
dramatic
screenwriting i mean dramatic writing um
i also was very fond of
of some of david mamet's essays and
books
i i took a couple courses
here and there and so i distilled it
down to
writing a premise or a log line um
for the for the um
the overall um um idea
of what the story would be and that that
premise or log line
has the um is
is elastic in itself meaning that it it
can evolve it can change over time
you can always return to it and augment
it in some way
as you are going through the writing
process and then
for each of the 12 beats
of my screenplay
so basically when i say 12 beats is if a
screenplay is technically 120 pages
there's a beat for every 10 pages
all right and then you're thinking of
of the story and we're talking the story
now
as an ekg all right so
um what i mean by an ekg and you can
also apply this to christopher vogler's
ideas on the the hero's journey as well
um the ekg is like you are you are
lifting off
with your inciting incident um the
inciting incident
um technically should occur anywhere
from like the five page
to to like well in the old days it was a
five page defer to 30 page but like it's
it's really just five pages now you
really don't go farther than that
and then um and then what you do is you
um
you plateau off as you get towards the
towards the middle of the ekg so that's
like
um page 60 and that means basically that
your characters or your protagonist is
um on his way to um
towards his journey and so that's beat
six
and then on on beat nine
um you are you are um
you are coming all the way down on your
ekg
um you're spiking downward because they
are
facing all their adversity and all of
their obstacles
that they must overcome that they may
never
they may never recover from
and then if they do recover and they do
succeed and they win in the end
then that ekg comes all the way back up
at 12. if they don't if they don't win
then that ekg comes all the way up at 11
and then goes sharply down at 12.
so that is
um that is basically um
that 12 point beat
outline now with the 12 point beat
outline
each one of those beats 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 10 11 12 has
its own premise so every 10 pages or
approximately 10 pages because you don't
have to adhere here
um strictly to
10 pages because you know maybe you have
a shorter script
[Music]
has its own log line so you go
this is know when such and such happens
such and such occurs cause and effect
it's a cause and effect statement that
is something
that is that has a whole chapter
in um lao los egries um the um
the the art of of dramatic writing is
the cause and effect statement
that goes all the way back that that can
apply
all the way back to the greeks and he
takes it there
so so um
you you you do that um for
each one of those beats um and then from
each one of those um
um log lines you use those as a basis
to to work on to script those 10 pages
or roughly those 10 pages
and then if you adhere to that
you'll you'll you'll probably get
yourself a um
a first draft um it may not be much of a
first draft
but it'll be something that you can you
can rewrite
and that you can work on now that was my
process back in the early days
um and that's how
i i figured things
out um once once you're
writing the second draft once i was
rewriting
at that point um that's where i start to
apply a little bit of those tricks a
little bit of the fun stuff
um that's
that's a whole other bit of tools and
things like that
um there's there's there's refining
that goes in with that sort of thing
um you want to
look at your script as
what is necessary in the story
and what and tried to
take out what is not necessary now um
this is one thing that i do believe
many storytellers fail to do
and it doesn't make them bad
storytellers
it's just their choice but some
some some storytellers
just overload their scenes
and they just want to do so much inside
of the scene
and it's not that you don't need to do
that to do a movie
uh to tell to tell
uh um a story um
for the service of a screenplay that is
to be
interpreted into a movie or a film
does not require it to be a play
[Laughter]
you know if you're going to beat a play
you can make a play you know
i write plays myself as well i think
that's fun
but it's not required it's a
it's it's something that you um you it's
a it's a story that you tell in pictures
um if i want to strike another analogy
um that analogy for me is that um
at a certain point for me and this goes
towards
the root of the question is that when
you get
you you you you figure out
your your voice it becomes a lot like
playing music
it's like you're not reading music
anymore
um you you while you play it
you're just kind of improvising a little
bit
and you're you're just kind of like
going with the feel
you know while you're you know you're
jamming or whatever
and um the classic example
um for me um is um felonious monk
because the thing about thelonious monk
that i loved
that reminds me of screenwriting is
that he has this
syncopation it sounds debris charles too
it's very it's also a great one um he
has a syncopation
that it's not the it's not what he's
playing
it's not the court that he's hitting you
know
it's what's between it it's the stop
it's in between it that that
that is where you feel
the story he's telling in the music
and then the same thing i believe
applies
towards towards a good screenplay you
know
um yeah yeah